hello we begin this NewsHour with the
historic deal that formally ended the
conflict in Northern Ireland it's been
25 years since the peace treaty known as
The Good Friday agreement was signed but
the road to peace was difficult for many
with more than 3 700 people killed
violence broke out between communities
in 1969. British troops brought in to
keep the peace became the target of
armed attacks themselves the conflict
was between mainly protestant unionists
who wanted the northeast corner of
Ireland to remain part of the UK and
Catholic nationalists who wanted to see
Ireland United the large-scale fighting
maybe over but tensions remain Al
jazeera's Andrew Simmons has more from
Belfast
their expressing gratitude for 25 years
of Peace but those working to bring
divided unionists and nationalist
communities together believe
reconciliation is a long way off
right in drawing our communities
together and in
uniting our hopes for the future in us
saying that the other is no or should be
no threat
that we can coexist in the way that many
communities across the world manage to
achieve
the hatred and distrust was born of a
30-year conflict
3700 people died more than half of them
civilians paramilitaries from the Irish
Republican Army wanted the British army
out
Protestant gunmen mounted their own
campaign
it ended with what some observers called
a political miracle
power sharing was a central prop but the
main players Democratic unionists in the
dup and nationalists in Shin Fein have
been at odds right now the seat of
devolved government at Stormont is
defunct after the dup walked out in a
dispute about EU trade laws and brexit
Alan McBride is among those accusing
politicians of letting their people down
in 1993 an IRA bomb in Belfast shankill
Road killed nine people his wife Sharon
was one of them we have a relative peace
here in this country at the moment we we
don't have reconciliation we still have
Shen fee in the deep in each other's
throats it's very simple I believe that
we need uh more kindness in our politics
and I think for far too long uh both
Shen fian and the dup have only ever
really cared about what matters to them
the big question is still this how can
Republicans and unionists somehow accept
their respective Traditions their
cultures their identities when they're
synonymous with such a violent history
on Tuesday the U.S President Joe Biden
will be visiting Northern Ireland he's
known to be concerned about the effects
of political instability on The Good
Friday peace agreement
we can now bring in Andrew Simmons he's
joining us from Belfast so Andrew 25
years on how solid is this agreement now
well it's established it's well
established it's had the effects it want
they all wanted particularly the
political leaders and Rishi sunak uh the
prime minister of the UK has praised
those political leaders who managed to
sign up that deal as being brave having
persevered and having political
imagination and amazing achievement
however there are concerns there are
worries about the political instability
as I touched on in that report and it is
going to be the case that when uh prime
minister when the President Joe Biden
addresses the Ulster University on
Wednesday which is his main engagement
in Belfast that whether or not he will
touch on on that instability and make
any calls for more pressure on the
leaders of Northern Ireland to actually
get their power share power sharing
machine going again now it has to be
said that the brexit sit at the
post-brexit trade deal with the European
Union is a is a pressure point with the
unionists and that is spiraled to a
point whereby they don't take part in
government and nor de chin Fein and that
is a a major issue also a pressure that
could lead to areas of violence it has
to be said that no one can certainly
rate the violence as being that serious
as that much of a threat but it could
relate to political events so for
example here in Derry Londonderry is
officially called by the British but
dairy by the locals here where in 1969
on the Battle of bogside where there
were riots and clashes between the two
communities where many historians feel
the so-called troubles began there is
some tension right now because there are
dissident Republicans on an unauthorized
March in an area called the Craigen
that's taking place later on uh also
there is so worry about former loyalist
paramilitaries because they are upset
about that post-brexit deal so the U.S
president is going to have a lot to look
at whether he'll say a lot is another
matter all right thank you so much
Andrew Simmons reporting for us from
Belfast
well Al Jazeera spoke to two young men
born the year the deal was signed so
they shared their hopes for the future
my name is Joshua Murray
I'm from a Catholic background in
Northern Ireland
on the news every day you heard about a
bombing shooting something Dreadful that
was happening and this was something
that was kind of interspersed throughout
Northern Ireland that was something that
sort of affected life in every way
[Music]
my name is Zachary Hutchinson
and I come from a Protestant background
here in Northern Ireland
still quite a divided
Society especially at that point very
much based on on religion between
Protestant and Catholics it was still
very much a dark dark place even kind of
in those more rural
War you would term tranquil areas by the
Sea you know there was still um still
atrocities that occurred the agreement
creates new institutions a Northern
Ireland assembly
to restore to the people the fundamental
Democratic right to govern themselves
there was a sense of kind of hope and
optimism they on the 10th of April in
19th it wasn't there in previous
um in previous decades that sense of a
new start of a change of trajectory of
of Hope for for Northern Ireland for the
older generation there is that history
of violence and therefore the history
the kind of suspicional mussarich side
will have towards one another it will
probably be lesser and lesser as time
goes on but I don't think it'll ever
really go away I believe in in Northern
Ireland I believe that it will have it
does have a prosperous future ahead of
it regardless of the difficulties that
are there
um that it's there's certainly cause for
optimism and then hope
there's no dive that Northern Ireland
with the divided neighborhoods with the
divided schooling system that exists
here remains very much divided I think
only 13 of pupils in Northern Ireland
attend integrated schools that means
that 87 go through an exclusively
Protestant school or an exclusively
Catholic school so
a lot of today's children are still
growing up divided from one another
there is a growing sense of Northern
irishness across Northern Ireland I
think the census results actually
reflect that as well that more people
are identifying as Northern Irish rather
than Irish or British there's still a
way to go I suppose before Northern
Ireland resembles a normal functioning
Western society as I've gone grown older
I've realized actually there is more
that the United States than divides Us
in terms of faith those two communities
are here and probably will remain here
but thankfully not being violent
generally towards one another and living
in relative peace
let's not speak to Deirdre Heenan who's
a professor of social policy at Ulster
University Belfast that's in Northern
Ireland joining us from there welcome to
the Al Jazeera NewsHour so you know many
people say that there was an agreement
that took enormous political courage and
vision to achieve but 25 years on how
fragile does this agreement remain
recognize the trans informational nature
of the Good Friday agreement it is
absolutely revolutionized a society in
Northern Ireland and indeed politics in
Northern Ireland it brought to an end
what we thought was an intractable
conflict where over 3 700 people lost
their lives and many thousands were
injured and had life-changing injuries
so I think it is important that we don't
gloss over the fact that this was a huge
moment in our history and something that
many people would thought they would
never live to see it is true however
that it has been an imperfect Pace that
peace in Northern Ireland has been
fragile and volatile and that our
government for example we agreed many
principles in the Good Friday agreement
those principles are unmutable those
principles are around respect uh Power
sharing and understanding of each other
reconciliation
um and so what we are saying is that we
need to go back to those principles and
ensure that we can build a prosperous
future based on the principles that
those Visionary leaders agreed 25 years
ago right and we have the visit of the
U.S President Joe Biden
coming to Northern Ireland because of
course the U.S did play a key role at
the time in brokering that agreement how
significant is his visit in and what
will you be looking out for
well I think his visit is hugely
significant we are honored to have such
interest from the US and in particular
this Irish president who who uses his
irishness he he wears his irishness on
his sleeve but he is deeply interested
in the island of Ireland and this is not
a recent thing this is something that
has marked his presidency but also
marked his political career I think it
is shoot significant that he has decided
to spend time to come and visit us of
course I'm delighted that this visit is
happening on our new 350 million pound
campus in the center of Belfast a campus
that we couldn't have drained off two
decades ago and so he is coming there
and we're hoping that the focus will be
on the future we're looking at a very
different backdrop than we were 25 years
ago yes we have that relative peace and
stability now what we need for our young
people is prosperity hope and what
Northern Ireland is crying out for at
the moment is leadership leadership and
ambition we need our politicians to get
back into government to understand that
there are a generation of people who
feel that they have been failed by this
Good Friday agreement but what they want
is prosperity the hope of a stable
future yeah and of course the government
has been paralyzed they'll just allow me
to jump in for a second the government
has has been paralyzed and that was as a
role as a result of a dispute over trade
rules so when you look at the issue of
brexit and what's happened in the past
few years how much does brexit pose a
threat to the agreement
it poses a threat to the agreement but
it was quite clear when the EU when the
UK decided to lead the EU that would
have a destabilizing effect on this
island that we are the only part that
shares the only part of the UK the
chairs are Frontier with the EU so there
were many warnings about how this could
destabilize a fragile peace process in
fact John Major and Tony Bear came to
the city of Derry and said that you know
what would we do about the Irish Border
and warned that if we left the European
Union that pieces of the Constitutional
jigsaw would be thrown up in the air and
no one seemed to know where they would
land those warnings were largely ignored
and the difficulty is brexit means
borders borders are baked into brexit
and of course people realize that that
would have a destabilizing effect on a
on a fragile peace process so post
brexit we now have the Windsor framework
and we want that Windsor framework to
work because it allows us to dual access
to the EU and the GB markets right we
also have an old economy and so it
really gives us a unique opportunity to
look forward bring inward investment and
bring the prosperity that was promised
25 years ago thank you so much to
draheen and for speaking to us from
Belfast